- In triangle ABC above, AB,
the length of this
segment, is equal to AC.
E is the midpoint of AB.
Well they really haven't
drawn this to scale.
Let me see if I can draw a
little bit more to scale.
So they're saying E is the midpoint of AB.
So the midpoint looks
closer to around there.
So it would look like this.
This is A, this is E, this is B,
that is D and that is C.
So let me mark this off.
E is the midpoint of AB
so that means AE is equal to EB.
And D is the mid point of AC.
We know that AC is the same length as AB
so AD is going to be
the same length as that
which is also the same length as that
which is the same length as that.
If AE is equal to x--
So AE, this distance right
over here is equal to x.
And ED is equal to 4.
So this is ED is equal to 4
so this length of this
segment right over here is 4.
What is the length of BC?
What is the length of BC here?
Now the key thing that
might jump out at you
is that we're dealing with
two similar triangles.
That triangle AED
is similar to triangle ABC.
And how do we know that they are similar?
Well, their corresponding
sides have the same ratio.
The ratio AC is twice AD,
AB is twice AE
and then they have a
common angle in between.
So AED is similar to triangle ABC.
Let me right this down.
So triangle AED
is similar
to triangle ABC.
And what that tells us
is the ratio between
corresponding sides is
going to be the same.
Now, BC is the corresponding
side on the larger triangle,
on triangle ABC, to this side, side ED
on the smaller triangle, on triangle AED.
Now what's the ratio between
corresponding sides of ABC and AED?
Well, this length is x,
we've already been told that,
this length we know is two x.
How do we know that?
Because E is the midpoint.
So the ratio between
the corresponding sides
of the larger triangle
and the smaller triangle,
the ratio is two x to x
or the ratio is just two.
Or another way of saying it
is the corresponding side
of the larger triangle is twice
the corresponding side
of the smaller triangle.
So if this is four, this is
just going to be twice four.
It's going to be eight.
So the length of segment BC is eight.